another question relating to travel
travel and
fast what's the minimum
distance of travel during which are
Exempted from fasting this is the same
answer as for Salah what is the distance
considered for a traveler so that he can
do KAS in his Salah shorten his Salah is
the same for fasting though the differ
opinion but the majority of the scholar
they say it is 16 far each farak is for
three miles so it is more than 48 miles
if a person travels or if a person
travels more than 80 km he's considered
as a traveler but some Scholars say it's
83 some say 84 km so be in the safe side
more than 80 km more than 84 km a person
is considered as a traveler but the
basic thing is he should not be in his
own Hometown there are some cities which
are very large and the distance from one
end of the city to the other endend can
be more than 84 km then he's not
considered the traveler he should be in
a foreign city